I love the way you are dressed and in
these in these roles in this particular
and we have a picture here that I it's a
poster I have there you are
yeah exactly and can you explain what's
that what's going on is that it was that
a necklace or because I first thought I
thought was like a monocle or Looking
Glass is that a necklace what a big
monocle yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
does seem big doesn't it Andy I think
you probably don't know how to use it no
no I know I'm looking at him those are
more than what you probably think now
I'm just scared
google it okay so wait what made you was
that your acting choice to wear a it was
an aquatic it was an active choice it
was one of those things where like
they've laid out the jewelry and I just
gravitated towards that beautiful put it
on and I was like this is unique yeah
and cool and so then I just kept trying
on the other bits of her wardrobe and I
just kept it and then it's amazing great
you chose come again
what and then I said yeah cuz I hadn't
know I know we're just saying all sorts
of on the outward don't worry about
it this hair is this airs very late on
Nickelodeon
[Applause]
you